rushi sunak isn't the only one with a
black hole in his budget his former
hometown of Southampton is in the bottom
20 of deprived areas and people like Zoe
looking for bargains at the one pound
clothing shop need all the help they can
get let's just hope he brings out Energy
prices right down our electric has gone
from
okay amount to absolutely ridiculous
amount
um like it's just it's too much it's too
much money going into gas and electric
what is it you feed your child or you
don't feed your child
this powder piece shop opened just three
weeks ago and sells 80 items a day the
owner says it's a sign of the times
sunak will have to face
we'll see you later on this week
well thanks see you later bye
Southampton recently applied for
Millions from the government leveling up
fund now soon it will decide what
leveling up means
[Music]
the postal workers on this picket line
on Shirley High Street it means wages
meeting inflation
he needs to change the landscape so it's
not so much of a problem oh we haven't
got problems with our entrepreneurial
people being creative and making
business and doing well and stuff like
that they should be paid more they take
on more risk and responsibility but the
the difference now is just so
substantial it's just unbelievable some
people are in graphic poverty and some
people are living the complete Life of
Riley it's just totally wrong but the
Prime Minister has competing demands
Southampton General where the Prime
Minister was born now has a record 50
000 people waiting for treatment and
during the leadership debates with Liz
truss Rishi sunak promised to put the
NHS on a war footing and Tackle waiting
lists the last Chancellor scrapped the
social care Levy but Leslie Jones
visiting her husband in hospital who's
recovering from a brain tumor says his
treatment depends on social Care at the
moment he's being well cared for that
he's not having the rehabilitation that
he really needs right now so it's the
bed blocking it's the moving on and I
suspect it's at the very end of the line
where people need to be moved out of
Hospital into social care yeah and it's
all the care places
son of a GP and a pharmacist tunak
worked in this shop and he did shifts at
cooties Indian restaurant where Jazz
Singer Lucian got to know him and says
he deserves support we all need to club
together have faith and get everyone
believing that we can actually get
things changed unite and go forward with
him to make things work he needs support
the nation's support absolutely
Richie sunac says his priority is
economic stability that the boy from
Southampton has his challenges stacked
up
Jason Farrell Sky News